At its core, building AI agents is
rather simple when you just have an LLM
that you want to connect to a couple of
tools, especially with the help of no
code tools like N8N and AI coding
assistants. But when you really want to
start to tackle more complex problems
and build truly robust AI agents, it
becomes a lot less of a walk in the
park. And something I get asked all of
the time is how do you just look at a
problem and know the AI agent to build
for that and the different components to
build into it? And that is what I want
to share with you right now. I want to
dive into my powerful mental model for
building agents. Because essentially
over the years, I've built a framework
for myself for taking any complex
problem revolving around AI agents and
breaking it down into bite-sized chunks
to make it easy to build. Let me show
you what I mean. Clearly, you can see
that I have a lot in store for you. I'm
holding nothing back sharing my full
mental model with you. and we're taking
advantage of how visual N8N is to make
this very easy to follow along and I've
got a lot of very easy to grasp examples
as well. So I want to make this as
simple as possible covering the concepts
that you can combine together to then
make more advanced AI agents. So, the
mental model that I'm going to be
sharing with you now, I'm calling the
seven node blueprint for AI agents.
Because any AI agent that you could
possibly dream of making can be broken
down into components that are going to
fall into one of seven categories. And
those seven categories are what I want
to focus on here. Because really, any
problem in life can be made easier by
breaking it down into smaller
components. And that is what this
blueprint gives us. It's a guide to do
that for building AI agents. And so
we'll dive into these seven different
nodes. But the first thing that I want
to cover with you is the core principle
that guides this entire process. The
reason I call it nodes, the seven node
blueprint is because of this right here.
This is just so important to understand
that agents under the hood are really
just graphs. Well, that's cool, Cole.
But why is that important? What does
that even really mean? Well, let me take
a couple minutes and explain this to you
because this really is the core of our
mental model. And I'll start here with a
diagram from the lang chain
documentation covering what an AI agent
is at a high level. So we have the input
from a user. This goes into an LLM that
can take actions on our behalf with
tools. And then we produce the final
output after the agent is done running.
And if you take a look at this diagram
closely, you'll see that this is really
a graph. We have this cycle here. And
this applies to any AI agent you could
possibly make where you have this cycle
of the LLM deciding to use a tool,
getting feedback and reasoning about
what happened when it used that tool,
and then it can invoke more tools. Like
this cycle can repeat any number of
times just based on the reasoning from
the LLM. And this is very different from
traditional automations and workflows
where we follow a much more linear and
deterministic path. We always have some
input that is processed in some way in
the exact same way every time and then
we have the output at the end. But with
agents, we have these cycles of
reasoning now with these tool usage and
we can have agents that are working with
each other and we don't necessarily know
like for one execution. Is one agent
going to use this tool or call upon this
agent? We have that non-deterministic
behavior that is facilitated by the
cycles that we have in a graph. And so
that is why agents can be thought of as
graphs. And the reason that that is so
powerful for us is because when we have
these different cycles and these
different nodes in a graph, that allows
us to reason about how we break the
agent into smaller components. And
that's what we're going to dive into in
this video is taking a look at more
complex AI agents, the different parts
that go into it, how we can focus on
just subsections of the graph and build
those out. And also, you can kind of
think of these graphs as just being a
bunch of Lego bricks that are put
together. Like you have a guardrail for
your agent. We'll get into that. We have
your tools. We have your fallbacks. And
you can build each of those
individually, combine it all together to
make a truly robust AI agent. And that
is what we're going to be doing together
with our framework. So here's an example
of an AI agent that uses all seven nodes
in its process. And this is supposed to
look a little daunting for you. That's
the point that I'm driving home is that
we have these more robust agents that
might seem hard to digest. We can break
them into smaller components. And so I'm
going to be walking you through each of
the different components here like
long-term memory and our fallbacks and
our guardrails, focusing on those
individually. Then we'll come back to
this example. See how they all combine
together to make this more robust AI
agent. And for each of the examples,
including this one right here, I even
built out a diagram so you can really
see what's going on under the hood and
an even simpler level than the N8N
workflow itself. And so what you see
here is essentially what we have in this
diagram. And there's a lot of components
here, but that's why we're going to
focus on each of them one at a time.
Now, let's dive into each of the seven
nodes. Then I'll show you an example for
them all after as well. So the first
node that we have is our LLM node. This
is the brain of the agent that has all
the reasoning and decision-making. And
so when you're interacting with GBT 4.1
or Gemini 2.5 Pro or Claude 3.7 sonnet,
all these LLMs that you're familiar
with, they are all operating within the
LLM node of our agentic workflow. And
then when they want to take action on
our behalf, that is when they leverage
the tool node. So this is our node that
performs the web search or the code
execution database queries and the
decisions made by the LLMs are going to
be invoking these tool nodes when they
want to perform actions for us. And then
the third type of node is a control
node. And these are very powerful
because AI agents are pretty
unpredictable because we're giving them
the reasoning ability to decide what
they want to do. And so control nodes
add a little bit of deterministic
behavior to our Gentic workflows because
instead of using an agent to run the
logic here, we're just using regular
workflows or code. So we have some more
deterministic behavior built into our
flow. And so this will handle things
like filters, conditions, routing as
well. So if we have output from an agent
that is going to dictate what path we go
down in a graph, the control node is
going to handle that. It's going to
route based on what the AI agent
outputed, and it's going to do that in a
deterministic way. And then we have our
memory node. This is both for long-term
memory and short-term memory. So we have
vector databases for long-term memory,
conversation history for short-term
memory. Typically what you'll have in
your agentic workflows where you want to
implement this is you'll have some kind
of node at the start and the end to
manage the long-term memory for your
agent as it is conversing with your
users or yourself. And then we have
guardrail nodes and these are crucial to
make our AI agents much more reliable.
You have both input guardrails and
output guardrails. So before you are
using an LLM that's connected to a bunch
of tools, you might want to validate the
user input or validate the output of the
agent against some rules that you have
defined. And you can use LLM as these
guardrails. You can use deterministic
code. We'll get into that more in a
little bit, but guardrails are just so
important to make sure that we're
filtering bad outputs, that we're
validating the format of inputs and
outputs. super crucial just to make sure
that our AI agents don't run a muck and
totally hallucinate something that is
going to make the whole agent fail
entirely. And then we have fallback
nodes. So when something goes wrong with
our AI agent, instead of just ignoring
the error or crashing the application,
most of the time we want to do something
specific like have our AI agent retry
whatever it was doing or producing some
default response for the user letting
them know that there was an error and
how they could try again. Whatever that
might be, we just want to make sure that
we handle errors in our agentic
workflows gracefully. And then the last
kind of node is the user input node. So
a lot of times even in the middle of an
agent operating, we want to get some
kind of feedback from the user or
confirmation that they want to move
forward with whatever tool the agent
decided to use. So like before we
actually use the agent to book a hotel
with Airbnb, maybe we want to send those
details to the human and confirm like do
you actually want to do this? Like does
this look good to you? And so this kind
of interrupt that we have, it's called
human in the loop. if it's an interrupt
that we have in our agentic workflow
waiting for the input from the human
before we continue and I'll show you
what that looks like as well. So these
are all of the seven nodes and we're
going to dive into an example for each
of them and then at the end I'll go back
to that more complex example combine
everything together so you can see very
clearly how we can start simple build
like with the Lego bricks like I was
saying earlier into something that is
more robust. So this first example
should look very familiar to you because
this graph that we have which represents
this NAN workflow looks exactly the same
as the diagram that we saw earlier. We
have the input that goes into the LLM
and tool loop and then we have the
output at the end. And this is the core
of building any AI agent. So if you've
built any agent in N8N before, this
should look very familiar and simple to
you. And we're knocking the first three
out of the seven nodes down with this
single workflow because we have the LLM,
we have memory, at least short-term
memory in this case, and then we have a
single tool that we're giving to our
agent. Specifically, this tool allows it
to create records in our Air Table table
that we have right here where we're just
going to list out a bunch of dishes that
we have. And so I can go back to my
agent. I can now ask it to make two new
dishes. And because we're asking it to
make two dishes, it's going to invoke
this cycle two times. And so we can see
that right here that we used our air
table tool two different times. And now
we have two new dishes. For some reason,
GBT 4.1 Mini just loves spicy mango.
Like it repeats this a lot even from my
earlier testing too, which is kind of
funny. But anyway, we built two new
dishes, five and six, and we used that
tool two times to accomplish that.
Really, we used each of these nodes two
times. So, we definitely had a lot of
cycles going on here in this graph
managing our tools and memory. So, in
the last example, I showed you a memory
node with short-term memory, but usually
when I think of memory nodes, it's more
for long-term memory. So, I wanted to
give you this example here. So, in this
graph, before the input goes directly
into the LLM, we're actually adding in
this memory retrieval step. And in a
more robust memory implementation,
you'll typically have this as a vector
database. you'll pull relevant memories
to then feed into the prompt for the
LLM. And then we have a step at the end
of the graph execution as well to
extract relevant memories from our
current conversation and store those at
the end. And so usually you'll want to
implement something like the mem zero
library for long-term memory. And you
can see with their add function when you
add memories to the vector database, it
itself is a graph, which just further
proves my point that agents are just
graphs under the hood. But anyway, so
you'd usually want a more robust
implementation like that. For a basic
example here, I'm just using a Google
doc to manage all of our long-term
memories. And so I can say something
like I hate spicy mango. And this is
going to then be fed into the LLM. It's
going to extract that memory. Like right
here, it extracts the memory. User
dislikes spicy mango. We're doing that
with an LLM that runs after our primary
agent. And then it's going to store that
in our Google doc. And so sure enough,
our Google doc now has the information
that the user dislikes spicy mango. And
so now I'll refresh the conversation. So
we're not using short-term memory. This
is using long-term memory. I'll say,
"Make me a dish based on what I don't
hate." Just some really silly example
here. So it's going to pull the memories
that we have from our Google doc. It's
going to feed that in as a part of the
prompt to the LLM. So right here, we're
we're adding in the long-term memory,
and then it's going to produce the dish
for us. Since you don't like spicy
mango, here's another dish and it gives
us a sweet mango chicken salad. So, it
stuck with the mango still, but at least
it's not spicy. That's actually
hilarious. But yeah, so you can see that
it leveraged the long-term memory there.
Typically, we would do something like
storing the memories in a vector
database instead of just a Google doc.
But that just gives us a very visual
example here. The sponsor of today's
video is Bright Data and their very
impressive MCP server. This is your
universal solution to give your AI
agents unblockable real-time access to
the web. And this is much more than just
web search. This is giving your agents
the ability to use the internet any way
a human could. They have a whole suite
of services to make sure that you can
handle any kind of web page, solve
captures automatically, handle complex
JavaScript, not get blocked from sites.
They have it all. And they even have
specific web scrapers that are built for
you to use out of the box for pretty
much any platform you could dream of.
And the star of the show that I want to
show you here is their MCP server. You
can take all of their scrapers and
proxies and other services and bring
them right into your AI agents. So in my
case, I'm using Pantic AI, my favorite
agent framework to connect my agent in
just a few lines of code to the Bright
Data MCP server. So, with this script in
total, less than 100 lines of code, I
now have an AI agent that can use the
internet in pretty much any way
imaginable. And so, for example, I can
have it get me the BIOS for Amazon and
OpenAI from LinkedIn. And it'll
intelligently use the LinkedIn specific
scraper as one of the tools that the
Bright Data MCP server gives me. And
take a look at that. Here are the BIOS
for Amazon OpenAI. I can confirm, I
checked this off camera, this is indeed
the correct BIOS. This is looking so
good. It's lightning fast. And I can
even ask it something else like, "Give
me the flights from Minneapolis to San
Francisco today." And it'll figure out
the best flights for me and recommend
them here. Take a look at that. All
right. Gave me four options. This is
looking so good. And it's just amazing
how it can intelligently pick the right
tool to use so that basically no matter
what I want to get on the internet.
Bright Data is able to do that for me. I
just love it. And so I'll have a link
below to Bright Data and their MCP
server, they've got free credits to get
you started. So definitely dive in, get
this kind of capability into your own AI
agents. It's just so powerful. So, next
up, we have both the user input and
control nodes. And these two different
types of nodes often go in tandem
together, which is why I wanted to give
you this example. They definitely don't
have to be used together all of the
time, though. But what we're doing in
this case is we are adding in human in
the loop. And so, our agent has this
tool to send a Slack message. But before
we actually follow through and send that
message, we're going to get the human
approval. And so, we'll see this in a
little bit. But when we get that
approval request, that comes into our DM
here in Slack. And then when we approve
the message, it'll send it here in this
research channel saying here is the
approved message. And then just for
demonstration purposes, if we deny the
message, like we don't approve it, it'll
still send it within Slack, but it'll
just say that this was the uh
disapproved message. So going back to
the workflow here, the way that this
goes is that we have the human in a loop
that's then connected to our control
node. So this is that deterministic
routing logic. Like I mentioned earlier,
control nodes are great for routing
because we want the same thing to happen
every single time we approve the message
or deny the message. So that's what
we're doing here. We don't have this
agent reasoning about what to do based
on the approval. This is the same
deterministic code that'll run every
single time. And so let's go ahead and
do something. I'll say make a new dish
and send it in Slack. And so it's going
to now leverage this subworkflow tool.
But we'll see in a second that this will
turn purple because now it is waiting
for our approval. This is our signal in
N8N that it's waiting for us to do
something before it continues with the
rest of this workflow. So I'll go on
Slack, go into my private DMs, and there
we go. It is introducing a new dish,
citrus infused grilled chicken with
mango avocado. So it still has mango in
the recipe. I love it. All right, so I'm
going to go ahead and approve this here.
We get this popup from N8N letting us
know that the workflow completed. We can
see this here. Everything is green now
in N8N. And then if I go back into the
research channel, here we go. Here is
the approved message. And we got our new
dish. Looking good. And so in this case,
the control node went down this top path
in our graph. Sending that message
saying that it was approved. And then I
can just restart the conversation. Send
the same message here. We can see what
happens when we go down the bottom path.
And so it'll ask for our approval again.
This time it made spicy mango again. I
don't know why it keeps doing that.
There's literally no conversation
history. It doesn't know that it did
that a bunch already. So I have no idea
why it keeps coming up with this over
and over again. But this time I'll say
no. You already did that. I'm going to
decline now. Okay. So action recorded
and then into the research channel. Here
is the declined message because I don't
want spicy mango for the 100th time. I
have no idea why 4.1 Mini keeps doing
that. But yeah, there we go. We have
human in the loop with control nodes
together making this all possible for us
to approve things that can oftenimes be
high risk. Like if you have your agent
book a hotel or send an email to your
boss, a lot of times it could
hallucinate in a way where you'd want to
disapprove and have it retry, whatever
that might be. We just want to add
ourselves into the mix to make sure that
we have some say in what the agent is
doing. Now we have the allimportant
guardrail nodes. And this is how you can
make your agents more reliable by
validating the inputs and outputs to
your agentic workflow. So we have both
input guard rails and output guardrails.
And so this graph is a little bit
different than what we actually
implemented here because I just have an
output guardrail to make this simple.
But I wanted to show both and I'll give
you an example of both really quickly
and then we'll dive into this example.
So for an input guardrail, let's say
that you're building a travel planning
assistant. You give the agent your
budget, where you want to go, for how
long, and it'll plan an itinerary for
you. As a good input guardrail, you
might want to have an LLM that will
quickly evaluate if the budget is
actually reasonable for the trip. And
then if it's not, you would have some
kind of fallback where you tell the user
like, "Hey, your budget is not
reasonable. You need to adjust that
before you actually interact with the
travel planning assistant." That'd be a
really good input guard rail because if
you have the agent try to create an
itinerary and the budget is just
ridiculously low, then it's going to
hallucinate a lot. Like this kind of
input guard rail just prevents that from
ever even potentially happening with our
travel planning assistant. And then as a
good output guardrail, you want to maybe
make sure that the itinerary that the
agent produced actually is the amount of
days that the user said they want to go
on their trip for. So just be a really
simple thing just analyzing the output
making sure that the days match and then
if it doesn't you would have some kind
of fallback. Otherwise you would just
then output the final itinerary to the
user. So good examples there of input
and output guardrails. What we're doing
in our case is we're going back to the
whole generating dishes here. We have
this agent that will make a dish based
on our request. And then we're going to
feed that into this output guardrail.
This is a critic node to make sure that
we're actually giving the necessary
information for our dish like including
the name and the description. Also the
origin of the dish. This agent, this
critic is going to output true or false.
Did this agent do a good job at giving
us a dish? And if it did do a good job,
then we're just going to output that to
the user. But if it didn't, then we're
going to retry. So we're going down this
bottom path in the graph. We're going
back to our original agent regenerating
the dish, but also with the feedback
from our critic node given so it knows
how to make a better dish this time. And
typically what you would do with these
kind of guardrail flows where you want
to retry the process is you would
actually have this loop go all the way
back around to the original agent. But
then you have to handle things making
sure you don't have infinite loops and
stuff. And so I have it set up in this
way just to keep it really simple here.
But just know that this would be more of
a cycle in the graph typically where
you'd have the self-evaluation or
critique whatever go back to the
original agent when you wanted to retry.
But anyway, that is our guardrail. And
so now what I can say is let me start a
new conversation. I'll just say make me
a dish that isn't spicy mango. We'll
cover this in the full example later
making sure we don't repeat the same
recipe. But in this case we created a
dish. How about a classic chicken
Alfredo? But we didn't give enough
obviously because the critic note here
said valid is false. And then it said
the feedback is the response does not
include the origin of the dish. And so
that's one of the things that we had
this output guardrail check making sure
that we have an origin. And so now that
goes back to our primary agent where
this time it's going to give us a dish
and then tell us the origin as well.
Take a look at that. All right. So we
got better output this time. Obviously,
this is a very silly example, but you
can think about how your output, you
want specific things included like the
origin of the dish, and this is your way
just to make sure that you can evaluate
the output to ensure that and then retry
if that isn't the case. So, guardrails
are super important, just reducing
hallucinations, making sure the output
matches what you actually need. So, the
last kind of node that we have to cover
here is our fallback nodes, and these
are super important to make sure that
we're handling errors in our agentic
workflows gracefully. We don't want to
just crash our application or ignore the
errors entirely. And that's what
fallback nodes are all about. And so
this is going to look very similar to
our control node example from earlier
because usually you use control nodes
with fallback nodes. And so we have our
example where we wait for approval to
send a Slack message. If we approve the
message, then we will go ahead and send
that. But now if we deny it, we're just
going to throw an error in the workflow.
And you can do something very similar in
Python code or whatever as well. within
N8N, we handle that with our error
trigger. So this is the process that
we're going to run anytime there's any
kind of error in our AENTIC application.
And so the powerful thing with fallbacks
is we can throw this error in any part
of our Aentic workflow, like not just
here. And then we're going to handle
those errors all in the same consistent
way. In this case, just sending a
message alerting that there's an error.
This could be an email. It could be some
default user response that you give back
letting them know that they need to
retry. whatever that might be, you can
handle that in this part of our fallback
workflow. And so in this graph, we can
see what this looks like. We have our
typical LLM into a loop. This goes to a
control node where we're either going to
take some action and then give the
output or we're going to hit some kind
of error and then go through this
fallback process. And so in this case, I
don't have an agent here because I just
want to keep it really simple. But I'm
going to test this workflow. It's going
to then ask me for approval. Please
approve or decline this message. I'm
going to approve it this time. and we'll
see it go down this path uh of not an
error like we just sent the message
here. But then if I test the workflow
again and this time I decline it. Then
we'll see it go down the path of the
error. And if I go to my execution
history, I can take a look at this. It
executed the error workflow. So I got to
zoom all the way in. Go back here. Now
it executed the error trigger here. You
can see that the error is an error has
occurred because that's the message that
I sent in here. And that is what I'm
going to send in this slack message. So
now in Slack, I'm just going to message
myself. So I say right here, an error
has occurred. So instead of sending it
in the research channel, I'm just
alerting myself internally that there is
an issue with this agentic workflow.
That is what we are able to do with
fallback nodes. Super powerful. Now here
is the big payoff. We can go back to our
full example. Now that we covered each
of the different nodes, we can see how
they combine together to build something
more complex like this agentic workflow.
So even though there's a lot going on
here, we can break it down step by step
to make it very very simple. And so let
me do that for you. I'll go through each
part of this process and I'll even point
out which node is being used in each
part. And so right off the bat, we are
fetching our long-term memory at the
start just like we did in our other
long-term memory example. Then that is
fed into this primary agent. And this is
going to again generate a dish for us.
But this time it has a tool to look at
what we already have in the menu to make
sure it doesn't generate a dish that is
already here, which is good because we
don't want to generate that stupid spicy
mango chicken thing for the 100th time.
And so we have our LLM, our tool nodes,
our memory nodes that we have for
long-term and short-term memory. And
then we also have this guardrail here.
So we're using what's called an output
parser to make sure that the format that
this LLM outputs always has a dish name
and a dish description. And the reason
this is a guardrail is because we have
this autofixing output parser. So if the
agent doesn't produce the exact format
that's needed, it's going to retry using
the secondary LLM to aid in that. And by
the way, if we were to give this
guardrail LLM some tools, this would be
another agent. And that's how you
implement multi- aent workflows as well.
You just have to have bunch of these
agents strung together, or you can use
agents as tools, like sub agents. And so
I know I didn't talk too much about
multi-agent workflows in general with
this, but if you just have a lot of LLM
nodes brought together, each with
different tools, that's how you build
multi- aent workflows. But anyway, just
a quick tangent there. So that's our
guardrail. Then after we create that
dish and we have the name and the
description that's guaranteed by our
guardrail, then we can send the message
in Slack getting that approval. And then
we have this control node that's either
going to hit that same error workflow
that's going to tell us internally that
there's an error with our agentic flow
or we're going to send that dish in
Slack and then we're going to add that
dish to air table as well. So because
this is not an agent performing this
action, this is yet another control node
just inserting that meal here in our air
table base. And then we're going to go
to the next long-term memory node. just
using another LLM to extract these key
memories. Like maybe we gave some
preference along with our request to
create a meal. Like we might have said
something like we like dessert with our
meal or we like dishes that combine
sweet and savory. So that's what we have
in our long-term memories. This will
keep adding on to that and we'll call
this node to save the memories as well.
And then we just have an LLM chain at
the end here that is going to summarize
everything and give us back that final
dish. And so going back to the start,
we've got LLMs, we got our memory nodes,
we've got our tools, we have our
guardrail here, we have human in the
loop. So we've got that user input, we
have these control nodes here to manage
the deterministic code, we have our
fallback, and then we have long-term
memory to wrap it up as well. So all of
these seven types of nodes we have
implemented in this flow. And so the
reason that this is powerful for us to
understand these different components is
we can reason about what we want to add
into this by just thinking like does
this agent need long-term memory? What
kind of guard rails do I want to
implement here for input or output
guardrails? What I want what do I want
to do when there's an error in my flow?
What kind of fallback do I want to have?
We can ask ourselves these questions one
at a time, breaking down this more
complex process into something that
starts to feel a lot simpler when we
think about it this way. That's the
power. like it wasn't that hard for me
to build this full flow when I just
thought about each of the seven nos and
what I want to implement here. So now we
can just test this out. I'll open up the
chat again and I'll say make me a dish
that isn't already on the menu. So just
making sure that it uses this tool to
check the menu so it can generate a
brand new dish for me. So it's going to
do that. It also pull my long-term
memory so it knows that I like desserts
with my meal. I like things that are
sweet and savory. So I'll go over to
Slack now. See what I need to approve.
coconut lime shrimp with sweet chili
couscous. That actually sounds really,
really good. Like my stomach is gurgling
right now. So, I'm going to go ahead and
approve that because that definitely
sounds good to me. And so, now going
back to the flow, it's going to send
that message in Slack. And so, I can see
that in my research channel. Here we go.
And then I also have it added to my menu
here in Air Table. Take a look at that.
And then let's see if there's any
memories that were added. I'll go to my
memory. Uh let's see. An important
detail is that the user wants a dish
that is not on the menu. Okay. So yeah,
now it knows going forward that in
general I don't want dishes that are
currently on the menu. So that looks
really, really good. Take a look at
that. And I know I didn't show the error
flow here, but that's just going to look
very similar to what we saw before. Just
a full example of this flow making a
very tasty dish that um I wish I could
go make right now. So there you have it.
That is my seven node blueprint, my
mental model for building any AI agents,
breaking things down into bite-sized
chunks to make it super easy to build
more robust AI agents. And I want to
create content on things specific to
like guardrails and fallbacks later as
well. So certainly stay tuned for that.
And then I'll continue to focus on
frameworks like Pantic AI and Langraph
that literally focus on agents as
graphs. Like that is the abstraction
that they have. It's just what makes
them so powerful. And so if you
appreciate this video and you're looking
forward to more things AI agents, I
would really appreciate a like and a
subscribe.